tout part d'un article du point nos
confrères rapportent cette phrase
l'inspection académique a contacté le
parent d'élève et lui a exprimé son
étonnement et le fait qu'ils allaient
sévir un extrait rapidement repris par
des médias comme valeurs actuelles et
des cadres du rassemblement national
mais c'est une phrase prononcée par adel
hakim ses fruits
militant islamiste aujourd'hui placé en
garde à vue la rectrice et la rectrice
et très vite visées sur les réseaux
sociaux selon une plateforme de veille
médiatique près de 5500 tweet évoque le
nombre de chars ni de la venelle en 24
heures hier en fin de journée l'académie
de versailles fait un communiqué de
presse
les informations sont qualifiés de
fallacieuses à aucun moment il n'a été
dit ni même sous-entendu ni penser que
l'institution allait sévir contre
monsieur patission ce communiqué de
l'académie de versailles fait aussi le
point sur le déroulé des derniers jours
et oui le 5 octobre dernier samuel pâtit
professeur d'histoire-géo donne un cours
sur la liberté d'expression avec
notamment pour supports des caricatures
de mahomet le court déclenché des
réactions de parents d'élèves
l'académie mobilise l'équipe valeurs de
la république ce sont des référents
intervenant au cas par cas dans des
situations relevant de la pédagogie de
la laïcité dans le traitement de
contestation d'élèves de comportement
inadéquat
un père de famille a ensuite rencontré
le chef d'établissement accompagné
d'abdelhakim ses fruits qui se serait
présenté comme un représentant des imams
de france
le père de famille interpelle alors
l'inspection académique il rencontre le
site à la suite de ces rencontres que
deux vidéos sont mises en ligne des
vidéos au de ce père de famille qui
diffuse des fausses informations et un
strong on instrumentalise les faits pour
l'académie c'est surtout dans ces vidéos
que le nom et l'établissement de samuel
pâtissons donner une plainte a été
déposée par le professeur et par
l'éducation nationale qui s'est mise en
relation avec les services de police
l'académie conclu en annonçant qu'une
enquête de l'inspection générale a été
demandée